okay we're going to get started just let
me know if you can hear me hey Katie
okay can you hear me all right
good you can hear me awesome
okay so we'll just wait a minute for
everyone to log on
cool so people are just rolling in here
and as we're waiting another minute or
so I just want to ask you a question um
how many of you have like tell me about
your sleep problem is that is that it do
you have a sleep problem number one
number two visit is it severe isn't it
mild if you can just let me know that
would be great just because this is all
about sleep today we're going to talk
about tonight I'm going to see si get
some feedback from you guys
Linda works in a sleep lab well lets you
see some interesting things so some
people wake up every every few hours
let's see mild I have sleep apnea mild
wake up to the night CPAP every two
hours trouble falling asleep wake up
for how to get back sleep-deprived Wow
well you're in for a treat tonight
because we're going to actually see if
we can help you with that um restless
yeah I'm just making notes here we're
talking about restless leg syndrome wake
up every three hours Wow 23 years of
chronic insomnia okay can't turn off my
brain okay so I got the picture alright
so welcome to the webinar we're going to
talk about how to lose more weight while
you sleep and it's true it is true you
can lose way more weight when you're
sleeping in fact when you're not
sleeping
forget about losing weight it's not
going to happen now let's go ahead and
get into the slides let me just kind of
click this right here and I'm going to
try to find my slide there we go okay
some I did this webinar someone told me
how to expand this thing to make it
bigger um I'm going to try to do that
this time they said that press this
thing right here so I don't know if this
works but on on your side but it's it's
it's to the entire screen on my side so
maybe it does work I don't know but I'm
just going to keep going so we're going
to talk about you know weight loss but
like sleep is the number one barrier to
weight loss if I'm going to evaluate
anyone in my clinic the first thing we
have to fix is the sleep because nothing
else will work if that sleep is not good
and a lot of things it's kind of weird
because your lip it's almost like you're
doing nothing when you're laying there
all night but you're actually a lot of
things are happening in your body
especially with fat burning in fact you
burn most the fat at night not during
the day and so you know I see people
that are working out so hard they're
going to the gym they're trying to count
their calories but their sleep sucks and
they're not losing weight I just had
another lady um yesterday in the clinic
she only loose loses weight when she
sleeps so she has a really good night
sleep let's say she sleeps like eight
eight and a half hours she'll probably
was close to a pound of fat and I'm like
that is just amazing so sleep is like
the real key thing and so I wanted to
designate like a whole hour tonight just
to really thoroughly cover this topic of
sleep so we can handle it and it's going
to make your weight loss a lot easier
okay so let me just kind of go through
here so check this out each night you
have these what's called a circadian
rhythm and there's a certain wave of
hormones that come up and down and up
and down starting from about ten thirty
and going all the way to about eight
o'clock and there's there's typically
about four to five different sleep waves
and if you catch them
time you can ride the wave and get a
good sleep hopefully but if you actually
go to bed like past 12 you miss the
first wave and then now you have to wait
until these hormones kick in to push you
down into the in the deeper sleep when
you don't have this mechanism working
you pretty much just you're there's
nothing that pushes you into that deeper
sleep so let me just show you something
right here we come back here so what
happens is that there is something in
your body that pushes you into a deep
sleep it's not like like passive it's an
active push down wave in your body that
actually is keeping you calm in a deep
sleep and you actually go through four
different levels of sleep and I want to
cover that right now but I wanted to
kind of just explain that it's not
passive it's an active thing so the
growth hormone which is basically a
hormone that is released from your liver
and it it causes the most of the fat
burning it's one of the most powerful
fat burning hormones out there you have
like six of them this is the most
powerful and there's two things that
trigger growth hormone number one high
quality sleep actually it's three things
intense exercise and three protein small
amounts of protein three rock through
the day will stimulate growth from one
so growth hormone spikes between 12
midnight and 2:00 and 8:00 in the
morning and this is when the fat burning
hormone actually kicks in the most at
first two hours now that's where you
burn most of the fat so check this out
if you you're going along during the day
and then all of a sudden you go to bed
maybe like a 10:30 that's the ideal
scene is to go to bed at 10:30 and then
try to be sleeping at 11:00 that's what
I do and you're supposed to go on the
sleep here and the eye
no you're not sleeping now we're going
to show you why but this is this is what
normal is and if you can do that you'll
actually be very successful now the
question is how many hours you need you
need um five six seven eight
you actually need between seven and a
half and eight and a half hours to
really burn enough fat if you're if the
depth of sleep is not there that means
that you're going to need a little bit
more sleep okay because we need that
recharging effect now check this out
these are waves of sleep and there's
four 90-minute cycles you know some
people there's five some people there's
three but most people have a four cycle
wave waves right here and so you have
this light sleep which is called REM
rapid eye movement REM sleep is a very
active sleep it's not a deep sleep it's
where you dream and you could remember
your dreams and it's vivid I had a dream
the other night I was going told my wife
I was kind of weird it was like right
before I woke up had this dream that I
was going off the road and I kind of
didn't overcompensate I just kind of
eased it back up on the road and
prevented us from going off a cliff so
of course that woke me up right away
that was REM sleep
now if we look down here this is called
the Delta down here and the Delta wave
sleep is the rejuvenating sleep this is
where you want to achieve this lower
level fat-burning sleep it's when you
wake up and you feel refreshed in the
morning that's what we want okay so
that's the goal um check this out
there's a lot of studies that show the
relationship between sleep and fat
burning and in the pretty credible
studies and so I'm going to send
everyone these slides as well and I'm
also going to create notes on these
slides and I will send you those as well
and a link if you'd like after we're
done here but the point is that there
was a
let me just kind of pull out of here
there's this company that I work with um
that I see here I just want to see
there's some questions here
can't see slide slides aren't moving
stuck on growth hormones yeah there must
be a delay okay so no graph showing all
right that's fine all right as we go
through this keep letting me know if
this slides work okay because I can I
don't really need the slides but it
would be nice to show you some visuals
okay so there was this company it was in
Washington state and it was drug company
and they were talking to another company
that I work with that built my
assessment to look at the stress and
recovery inside the body it's a little
tool and said they wanted to get a hold
of this to do some research and in this
in the company ask well why do you want
to do this research and it was mainly
because they found a drug that induces a
delta-wave sleep and they found some
interesting incidental findings when
they do that
they found that people lose a tremendous
amount of weight when they take that
drug but it's really the sleep but
there's a lot of side effects so I mean
there's a lot of stuff going on with
sleep now with people trying to create
different drugs to put you in sleep we
don't want to do that we want to create
natural sleep
let's see chaos is you're talking about
the waves of sleep you just mentioned
down down here and data but LMC growth
hormone well um there's I'm just going
to show you there's four waves of sleep
right here and you have a very
superficial sleep and you have a deep
sleep and the deep sleep is where you
burn the most the fat and the
superficial sleep is when you get REM
sleep it's very active you have dreams
when you're in the Delta you may dream
but you don't remember your dreams so
that's a
all you need to know not that maybe I
could just pull it up one more time let
me just see I can do that I think I know
why I think I know why that happened let
me just let me see right here because I
have to click a button so can you see
this slide now the cycles tell if you
can see it the problem is there's a
little delay so it's hard to quickly ask
you a question ok good so I think you
can see it alright cool so I think the
problem is that I have to click this
little button and share with everyone
but now you can see what I'm talking
about so I won't be able to blow it up
but you could really see the different
slides now
the other thing I wanted to mention is
that I mean sleep doesn't just block
your fat burning' it does some serious
damage or a lack of sleep I'm sorry
doesn't just block your fat burning it
increases your appetite it actually
destroys your metabolism it increases
stress it increases the loss of muscle
tone ok so increases muscle loss muscle
tone loss you can type it in it and
causes fatigue of course we know that it
affects your mood and cause depression
in fact I would be curious to find
someone who is depressed that is also
not fatigue I mean it's also fatigued at
the same time because if you actually
improve the sleep on a depressed person
and increase your energy the odds of
them being depressed are go down are
very very low because they just they can
pull out of it a lot of depression is
really chronic fatigue syndrome so they
just can't differentiate depression from
body fatigue so that's right I actually
try to improve the energy so it also
increases the risk of blood sugar
problems and diabetes increases heart
attacks there's this guy in India he was
a business person and he would he was an
exercise guy he would go out there and
work out a hard core trying to be
healthy you
at five o'clock in the morning he only
got five hours of sleep well he dropped
out of a heart attack because the
increased risk of heart attack
especially if you're pushing your your
heart and you're exercising hardcore and
you're not sleeping a very bad idea it
lowers the immune system it decreases
your lifespan other than that it's
perfectly fine
I'm being sarcastic okay so most the
people are saying I could see the slides
some people say I can't see this last no
problem I tell you what when we're done
here I will send you the slides okay um
all right so so the point is that sleep
can really destroy almost every part of
your body so um let me just go ahead and
click this right here now just as a side
note I want to just wait till everyone
got on here I finally got my my new app
done and hopefully you can see this can
you see my new app um it's a dr. Berg
app and it's been weeks and weeks and
weeks and weeks so it's it's completely
dead now and I have it on an iPhone and
I have it on a Android so if you have
those smartphones go ahead and download
it it's for free and I put on there all
of my videos and I took the voiceovers
or the audios on all the videos and I
uploaded those too so you can check that
out um so and what I would really really
really really appreciate is if you guys
can write a review when you download it
that would be very appreciative um but
I'll just show you if I could just show
you my little iPhone right here see how
this works here
okay so this is the app you can't even
see it right so we got videos and I
think the lights reflecting it too weird
there we go yeah we just click this
right here and then you can watch all my
videos in one place so every week I'm
uploading more and more videos I have
about six hundred additional videos I
did not upload because I don't want to
upload them um all of a sudden so I'll
be uploading like one a day because I
just been creating a lot of videos so it
has the video audio and then it also has
this really cool thing documents so you
can download so you want to press open
if you press open
that's the download and then you could
zoom it in and check it out so I put all
my documents there so you can check that
out and then you go back to the app it
has updates audio its audio video and
documents so and then you can click if
you want to see new updates if you click
new updates it looks like there's like
two of everything that's not a bug what
that is that is um video and audio
release so they are the same they look
the same because they're just an audio
of the video so you can check that out
and that's cool so definitely give me a
review on that and also if you see
anything that you'd like me to improve
in that app just send me an email
because we're always looking for ways to
kind of tweak it make it better
so that would be great I just have a
quick question here and CKY says can you
answer a question about ketogenic diet
and nighttime weight loss sure what is
the question
maybe you want to know um if you would
do that diet will that help you lose
weight yeah if you combine the key the
ketogenic diet with weight with more
sleep that's a deadly powerful
combination
in fact the only thing you have to make
and that is adjust your fats because
some people will show fat burning in the
urine but the problem is that they don't
um they're not burning their own fat
they're burning the fat that they're
eating so they have to adjust the
dietary fats and not have too many but
other people can get a get away with
more eating more fat if you feel a
lethargic or you feel tired um what that
means is that you need vitamin b5 okay
you can be vitamins so someone sort of
patty scissors you're AB for iPhone or
Android it both regardless if you have
an Android iPhone it's it'll work on
both um please create an app for Windows
Phone oh that's interesting that's an
idea I'll have to do that I will have to
do that I will do that for sure okay let
me go back to these slides alright let
me just go here alright so check this
out there is a clock up in your brain
and it's a pacemaker and it's
synchronized to the dark and light
cycles and exercise does influences it
as well and the name of this clock it's
a real big word is called super Chai's
mechanical I don't worry about
memorizing that but it's right in it's
very close to the hypothalamus right in
the mid part of the brain when this
clock has a pre-programmed system that
basically allows you to go to sleep and
wake up and it's not a tiny mechanism
it's pretty cool so the reason I'm
bringing that up is because a lot of you
sit in an office all day you don't get
outside and this whole lighting thing
a situation so I do want to talk about
that the certain forms of light are good
for you and certain forms of life is are
very bad for you
fluorescent lighting iridescent light is
not good full spectrum lighting is the
best so that's what I want to cover
right now I'm going to show you a
picture of what I have in my office
and at home let me see if I can find it
well it's a slide a little bit later I'm
not going to jump into that but if you
went to the Home Depot or you went to I
don't know you went to any store that
sells light bulbs or even amazon.com and
order some full spectrum lighting you
should put that on a little lamp around
your computer because right now there's
a lamp or right button my computer that
has full spectrum light if I didn't have
that I would create a lot of strain in
my my computer my eyes and so it does
affect the sleep pattern so so the goal
is to get some light during the day out
some natural sunlight outside you know
it's hard in the winter but you need to
get out there because if you're in a
building all day long and you drive home
it's dark and you try to go to sleep
that is going to start to screw up your
sleep cycles right there because you
because what happens is we have the
situation where darkness triggers the
hormones that help you go to sleep light
inhibits those hormones okay so you have
that whole stimulus enriched in an
hibbott ending factor of the light and
dark cycle so we really need to figure
that out and I think the best way is to
get a simple inexpensive light bulb
maybe by your office or in your house
that you can have that you know shining
on a little bit on your face or in your
eyes actually really the key is the I
don't like shine the light inside your
eyeball but you can just put it so some
of the light goes into your eye because
that's the trigger is the retina the
retina is an extension of your brain so
your eyes are an extension of your brain
so
goes right in now look at how complex
this circuitry is in your brain and I
actually went through this and I just
kind of design this chart by taking a
lot of references and things just to
wrap my wits around it because there are
so many different electrical circuit
boards in your brain that are
controlling the sleep cycles and then go
down are affected by the liver and the
adrenal gland and the bladder and these
other parts of the brain but I don't
want to confuse you with that so I just
wanted to show you the complexity that
goes on and then when we get into the
last part I'm going to show you how we
can influence some of these circuits
because it's really just a circuit now
as we do this webinar I want to kind of
bounce back in forth to your questions
so Michelle says what kind of bulb was
that you want to get a full spectrum
light full spectrum lighting light bulb
or whatever I have them in kind of these
some longer bulbs and I have smaller
bulbs so Julie talks about I never
remember my dreams that is a B vitamin
deficiency Deborah let's see let's see a
question says I have a problem with my
body feeling very heavy if I go to the
bathroom at night is the bead deficiency
are you just talking about your whole
body being heavy
um yeah I try to clarify that I'm not
sure what you mean by that can hormones
work during a nap absolutely there's
nothing wrong with taking naps in fact
if you're not sleeping during the night
time it's best if you take a nap because
you can tend to recover some of that
sleep why if I'm sleeping around seven
hours and really good I'm not losing
weight oh okay
well here's the thing sleep is this one
factor there are many many other factors
that effect weight loss so just because
you're sleeping does not mean you can
eat what you want it doesn't mean you
can't exercise but if you're eating good
and you have the right eating plan and
you're exercising everything is really
cool and your body is really healthy
then you just plug in the sleep but
there's always a reason why you can't
lose weight sleep is one of the biggest
things so Dell says what about with hot
flashes well that's the next thing I'm
going to talk about hot flashes so we
wanted to kind of dissect the reason why
you can't sleep and it could be hot
flashes it could be your bladder
digestion pain let's just take from the
top hot flashes your adrenal glands are
the backup organ to the ovaries so
during menopause at fifty fifty two the
adrenal glands on top your top of the
kidneys they back up the ovaries during
menopause if those adrenals are weak
going in the menopause what's going to
happen is that all those problems with
your period and having bloating and
cramping are going to manifest in a
different way as hot flashes because
those women may get hot flashes they
usually had bad cycle cycles before
menopause so what does that mean with
hot flashes it's actually a estrogen
deficiency and it's a progesterone
imbalance it's really a low progesterone
but the best thing that I do is I use
that product ovary support right here
this this is a product a lot of women
have it's mainly for menstrual cycle
problems but I use it for hot flashes
because it handles if there's too much
estrogen or not enough estrogen and you
take three before bed and that should
handle your hot flashes it just has
remedies in there to help balance your
estrogen naturally but it doesn't have
estrogen in it because that you don't
want to take estrogen but hot flashes
will will be one source of and I'm not
sleeping and that that's what we need to
fix because the cause of sleeping
problems is different from certain
people okay so since right here
my friend recently had a uterine
ablation will this cause problems
estrogen it creates a trauma and uterus
and it could create problems with
sleeping why can I sleep more than four
hours even without having hot flashes
well we'll get to the other reasons
shortly
oh yeah Sean says you use ovary support
no I don't use I do not use ovary
support
I actually recommend it for women that
have flashes however I've had men have
hot flashes so I haven't recommend that
product though um what about night
sweats well that's the same thing as hot
flash as far as the remedy a
hysterectomy can this be a problem yes
because that forces the adrenals to have
to do like back up that organ absolutely
so yeah that is a situation when should
you take B vitamins before with or after
eating food the B vitamins typically you
want to take them more in the early part
of the day but um not always some people
when they take them can't sleep other
people can sleep better so I would test
it out at certain parts of the day but
really it doesn't matter with food or
without food or a certain part of a but
I like to have a little bit more in
morning because the vitamins can
increase energy and you don't want to
have that red fritter bed all right so
let me get back to the slides here all
right so we talked about hot flashes no
your bladder let's say your bladder wait
wakes up does anyone have any bladder
issues like you're urinating through the
night but at least once if you do
there's several reasons for that there's
really there's like four reasons one
would be maybe there's a fibroid and
fibroids are caused from excessive
estrogen so you would want to fix the
excess estrogen and that's an ovary
problems Wow so yeah everyone's actually
getting up her a lot all right so we get
fibroids it can cause it if someone has
fibroids one of the
best thing to do to shrink that is to
consume cruciferous vegetables you could
also the other thing that will help
shrink fibroids is doing a keep
ketogenic diet because when you eat
carbs
it does make think things grow like
tumors and cysts and so if you cut out
that all the sugars that will help
shrink the fibroid because insulin makes
things grow so does estrogen now also
enlarged prostate will also cause you'd
this comes from high testosterone so
there's any men listening in and you
have that the best thing to do for high
testosterone is to support the liver
with cruciferous a lot of cruciferous
vegetables that's the best thing I know
to actually balance the testosterone
because testosterone works with the
liver okay then menopause when women
have a problem with their bladder during
menopause it usually comes from a
decrease of estrogen so again the
ovaries support formula would help to
balance that now on occasion the person
is so depleted from estrogen I don't
recommend this routinely but only after
you tried everything else I would
recommend some organic non-gmo soy milk
because that will give you a little
estrogen to help you but I don't like to
do that but a small amount here and
there would be totally fine okay so let
me just I'm going to pause here and
answer some questions I was told my
problem is cortisol wake me up well I'm
getting to that shortly
I have thyroid symptoms and I've been
eating kale shakes for several months
which doubt should have follow
Kito or a moderate car plan well if
you're a thyroid type I would pretty
much do a combination of things because
if you're doing the kale shakes you want
to make sure you take some seek help
because you want to actually have more
iodine but usually thyroid is secondary
to the high estrogen or low gall bladder
I would suggest going to my youtube
channel and look
up those videos I have actually now just
go ahead and get my download my app and
you can check out all the videos on the
thyroid and I talked about the cause of
that let's see taurine yeah Torian is
good amino acid I've tried it with a
number of adrenal cases it's I'd seen
mixed results sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't someone wants to
know examples of vegetables well number
one the type of vegetables that you guys
need would be especially with the
cruciferous would be the kale of course
the broccoli that cabbage red cabbage is
really good I like arugula you can also
use bok choy any of the mustard greens
with chard those are some serious
cruciferous vegetables that will
actually help anti-cancer and also help
you know shrink a fibroid all right um
is soy okay for hypothyroidism well
again I'm only recommending the soy if
you have some serious hot flashes and
you've done everything and nothing's
work but I don't recommend silly if you
have a hypothyroid because the destra
gene will slow your thyroid down more
someone Claudia had a cervical cancer
and my uterus moved in to get my ovaries
radiated so now we know your adrenals
are working at over time and that's
going to put a lot of stress on
everything else so we're going to get to
the adrenal glands the last thing
okay now digestion let's talk about that
your digestive system has a whole bunch
of nerves in them you have actually more
dudgeon your digestive system than you
do in your spinal column so all those
nerves can go right up to the brain
and create a lot of problems with neck
muscle tension in your neck very active
brain so if you're getting bloating and
going the bed with a bloating stomach
that will easily cause you to stay up
all night so with some slight minor
tweaks with your digestive system and
this is a very important point I'm just
going to make a note because if you have
any digestive problems and you're going
trying to sleep you want to clean that
up
you know and it could be that you're
eating foods that you're bloating that
you shouldn't be eating like even the
cabbage or the broccoli or the cow if
you blow with that then steam it or eat
some other vegetables but you don't want
to bloat and go to bed because that's
going to prevent sleeping if your
stomach is really working good you'll
sleep a lot better because you have less
tension in your neck because all the
stomach stuff refers up to your neck and
the other thing is that you want to make
sure that you don't eat right before bed
so you're all bloated especially fatty
foods if you're doing the ketosis diet
and it's a lot of fat and protein you
don't want to do that late in the
evening because it's going to sit in
your stomach so it's very important to
go to bed
maybe with just like not necessarily
hunger but so you're not you don't have
too much food in your stomach okay so
that would actually help you Mary says I
awakened with charley horses in my legs
and gee well that is a calcium
deficiency so you need calcium magnesium
before bed um I was taking adrenal
supplements but I was super tired all
the time what is the best time to take
them well it really depends on what
supplements you have I'm going to
recommend my adrenal fatigue formula in
a little bit if you want something for
sleep that works really good and in the
adrenal de if you want something add
more energy during the day but it really
because there's some adrenal stuff that
that's good for just general boosting
you and there's other ones that calm you
down is drinking for 4 ounces let's say
for 8 ounce glasses of kale shake in the
morning too much uh no not necessarily
um especially if you're not putting too
much fruit in it I think you'll be fine
with that that camel is some really good
stuff just make sure you put some drink
some lemon juice somewhere in the day so
you can rig make sure you don't get any
stones any suggestion grinding your
teeth at night that's a B vitamin
deficiency and also someone says I'm
hungry when I wake up
um if that's a problem then maybe have a
little bit more food at dinner but I I
wouldn't worry about that too much do
you know about santa process elements
yes I know a lot about Santa process
supplements that use them for 20 years
that I've been to the farm six times
I studied royally so I'm I'm very
knowledgeable about that would a banana
be good right before that no because
it's a carb you don't want to do carsick
or beg what you want to do is you want
to do maybe some celery listen a little
bit of peanut butter maybe a little bit
of nut maybe some hummus with some like
celery celery something like that but
you don't want to do too much right
before bed
good questions by the way all right so
we talked about digestion now we want to
talk about pain now if you have pain in
your back whatever then you're not going
to able to sleep so we want to fix the
pain so you'd want to get that handled I
just did a seminar on how to get rid of
pain a lot of people flew out and came
to the seminar and a lot of people got
the program so if you wanted some help
with that you can get that
do-it-yourself version even if you have
low back pain or knee pain or whatever
and also I have a lot of videos on pain
you can check it out on my actually on
your new app okay now I'm going to talk
about heart your heart a tired heart
will keep you up at night as well and
I'm talking about high blood pressure
I'm talking about high pulse rate so a
lot of people when they go to sleep that
blood pressure try to sleep with a a
blood pressure like 150 over a hundred
you it's like too much pressure going on
the body so the simple remedy for high
blood pressure is vitamin k2 in d3 and
I'll show you that another slide that it
works like a charm
it actually strips off the calcium that
builds up in arteries and it will bring
your pressure right down but a high
pulse rate is a patan
see em deficiency okay so I think you
probably know this most of you because
I've covered this so many times but you
need about seven to ten cups of
vegetable per day to get your greens
okay so you need seven to seven to ten
cups and that would be like seven to ten
ounces so these baby lettuce leaf packs
in the in the grocery store they come in
these little packs so just read a label
how many ounces it is it could be 18
ounces and eat half of that so you can
do the vegetables you can do you can
blend your vegetables with kale you can
also eat other vegetables you want to
have a variety and so I'm always eating
combining a little red cabbage with kale
and arugula I love arugula and I'll do
spinach and I'll do this so you want to
mix it up but that vegetable will
increase potassium in your pulse rate
will come down a normal pulse rate is
like 70 but it gives people that it's
like it's over 100 so Claudius's
sometimes I wake up with a pounding
heart that's a low potassium so you need
more potassium in your diet um will
calcium magnesium help with achy legs no
there's something else for the rest of
leg and that would be vitamin b1 so so
it's the B vitamins okay but make sure
you don't get a synthetic vitamin that
will not work okay let me just pull this
up right here okay
now we talked about the heart now we
talked about so let's talk about sleep
apnea
alright sleep apnea sleep apnea is not
not a sleep problem it's a breathing
problem where the oxygen goes lower
because it's an obstructive thing but
check this out there's a nerve there is
a nerve that comes out of your brain
stem comes right of the brainstem it
goes to the back of the sinuses and that
nerve becomes atrophied it actually it
loses its tone when you have high levels
of cortisol adrenal stress and all the
back of the sinuses in the throat will
can actually become really lacks and
kind of hang out and create like a flat
there and obstruct your air so sleep
apnea is really an adrenal problem okay
so in other words we come back back to
the Drina so now we covered all the
other things now we're going to talk
about a dream because that's the number
one cause of sleep problems and I wanted
to cover that the last part of the
seminar because so many people have
stress Michelle asked a what about
meditation helping sleep Michelle I want
to talk about meditation I think you
should do the opposite of meditation to
sleep and so instead of like fixating on
something or focusing on something even
with your eyes closed or whatever I like
to extrovert myself before bed I like to
go for a walk in the evening and look at
things and get my attention going out
versus reflecting internally because all
day long I'm focusing on things I have
to reverse the flow and get out of my
head so like getting your sleep you know
what happens is that people have a
problem with their attention there their
attention is fixated on a certain thing
and they can't unfix ate it and just
turn it off like that so what they
should do is get involved in some
activity that you can control your
attention on
thing else that's not involving your
work your problems just pushing your
attention to something else because what
happens you go for a walk and you're
looking at the tree but you're thinking
about work then you're at work you're
thinking about the tree so we want to
control the attention by going out there
and looking at things and just observing
things and getting attention for about
an hour that's it's like a it's like a
thing you have to practice over and over
again but that's very very important
it's not bad to use a CPAP machine if
you need it as a transition but the
alien mask is not very comfortable so we
want to get it to the point we don't
need that and there's an acupressure
tool boom I have this this is it right
here the acupressure tool most of you
have it but this goes right in the back
of the neck on a couch or tall back
chair and you can set this thing right
for the second bone in the neck and I
have a a book that goes with it that
shows you how to do the sinus points and
this will open up your sinuses now why
because all the nerves that go to your
sinuses to the brainstem are right in
that area so you're actually steaming in
your nervous system in fact there's even
a very bad treatment that they're going
to launch and you're going to see a lot
more of this unfortunately in the future
they're using it's called Vegas
stimulation they're actually using
electric electricity implants in your
arm your nervous system specially the
nerves back there for all sorts of
conditions one for sleeping one for
sinuses four for sleep apnea I think
this is very bad because they're going
to put chips they can put right now they
actually have a in Harlem New York they
opened up the biggest brain center you
can see in Marik's
they're going to have a lot of children
come in there and study their brains I'm
nervous about that because they know
they're having this little chip that
they can insert into the brain and then
they can monitor different things and
create stimulation of the brain with
electricity which is I can just see what
is going this is like really bad you
know like anything with a chip that they
can control electricity in your brain is
bad is folic acid equivalent to b1 now
folic acid is a different B vitamin it's
one of the B vitamins but it creates
different effects okay and we'll get
into the B vitamins okay so now I want
to talk about this adrenal adrenal gland
right adrenal gland sits on the kidney
um it's a tiny little gland and it can
create a lot of misery for you so let me
just kind of talk about the oh here just
to the side now that heart blood
pressure vitamin d3 k2 I have some in my
website if you wanted to get mine but
it's I would take one to one ratio take
like three of each in the morning for
blood pressure works pretty good
again I'm not telling you it's going to
cure your blood pressure but just work
with your doctor but it's the remedy
that I've seen gos success with okay
adrenal fatigue let's talk about that
can you guys see my slides are you
tracking with me here I can't see slides
yeah Lorraine says do you mean a
conventional medicine a yes
conventional medicine Elect yeah it's
almost like certain companies are
shifting okay you can see myself certain
companies are shifting from certain
drugs into electrotherapy and I just
don't like it I do not like it at all
because I just I think you know shock
therapy is very bad and I don't like any
stimulation I mean even hospitals now
are doing this procedure they're putting
these electrical things and brains like
like a hundred a week in different
hospitals so I don't know where this is
going but it's not good okay so now
check this out there are some this might
be shocking to you but there are some
people that are addicted to caffeine
coffee I know it's hard it's hard to
believe that but um they need coffee to
wake up so caffeine alright so if you
need coffee to wake up chances are your
adrenals are pretty pretty tired now if
you are addicted to coffee maybe you
could just have one cup in the morning
and have it like a small cup public that
and just make sure that when you put
don't drink coffee in the evening or at
lunch only in the morning and then also
make sure that you don't put um sugar in
your coffee put xylitol in your coffee
and not honey
xylitol also if you want to put cream
put organic cream don't put that like
other cream it's not good so one of the
symptoms of adrenal fatigue is need for
caffeine in the morning and I had a
artist draw these by the way I think
they're pretty cool um thinking thinking
thinking how many of you do a lot of
thinking and you can't seem to turn it
off sometimes
does anyone have that problem go ahead
and let me know but here's what happens
with the adrenal um you're analyzing
everything and what happens is because
the adrenal has to do with survival well
everyone's doing a lot of thinking dude
renal clam is a survival gland and so if
you can think about what happens when
the adrenal gland kicks in the adrenal
gland adapts to stress and sort of
threatened survival states so an adrenal
gland gets burnt out it's way to
compensate is to activate all the things
that are like like your mind active mind
and your mind tends to solve problems so
you're solving problems like very very
fast
and that's all you do is solve problems
so your attention gets fixated on a
problem on plan a and then Plan B and
this isn't work Plan B and that's all it
does all day long it can't just extract
and not think about anything else and
it's all about fixing things and making
things better and then the tolerance for
anyone that is the opposite of that is
very low so insane people you can't
tolerate insane people slow people
incompetent people people that make
mistakes you don't have patience for
those people you might have a great day
but that one little problem just stuck
to you and that's adrenal okay so that's
going to affect your sleep because if
you're sleeping and you're analyzing
everything on the planet why beef right
before bed then it's just like a party
in your brain right you just can't turn
it off I want to see if anyone has that
problem oh yeah Doris is a human felt or
Michelle says that you've been following
me no haven't based on the symptoms you
described your videos identify myself as
so most adrenal fatigue yeah that's a
very very common um someone needs coffee
of dry drivers you can't stand them yeah
I hear you okay yeah
so we have this thing called racing
thoughts that is an overactive adrenal
and you know what happens is this all
stress accumulates and I want to
describe the stress and I'm not talking
about physical stress and talked about
mental stress I'm talking about threat
of loss bad things happen to people all
the time
in the wrong place you know and someone
loves you or you have a loss of loved
one financial disasters threaten a job
loss relationship stresses relative
stresses goals are achieved unhappy in
your job like all that stuff just kind
of builds on a person so you have to
actively extract
get from the body we're going to show
you some techniques but it is possible
to do that because all that stuff weighs
on the adrenal and in our society when
you actually on you get up in the
morning you're on your cell phone you're
on a computer and I don't really use my
cell phone very much because I am very
sensitive to magnetic fields I can feel
them and so I actually bought a magnetic
field monitor so I can check things and
I want to show you how this works so
okay now watch this is my cell phone see
how that goes up there so I don't want
this thing on my my head
so this basically the thing about
magnetic fields is that it alters it
alters the the adrenals and also the
brain it can affect you because now my
computer all my computer stuff is about
three feet over this way on the bottom
and I have my filing cabinet right down
here between me and the computer so how
that before I was feel like I was being
fried but what you can do is you can get
a quart an extension that goes into your
ear with a little mic right here not a
bluetooth just an earphone that you can
talk and you can listen that way you
don't have to have this right in your
head right here this stuff you talk on
the phone all day it's going to affect
your sleep okay you're on the computer
all day it's going to affect your sleep
you need a light a full-spectrum light
by your computers to offset some of that
that that light that's coming off the
computer which is not full-spectrum it's
pretty bad so I went through my office
and I'm just like finding everything
like it's all around me these electric
power cables and when you when you're
sleeping make sure you don't have any
electrical devices by your head now keep
them away and then maybe you want to
sleep in a tent in your backyard
this really does affect
yeah my husband says it's like me in
jackboots in a single lightbulb over his
head okay have you tried changing
yourself sitting at the computer
capacity yeah so basically we want to
undo some of the adrenal damage kind of
because see some people can't sleep yet
during the day they're so tired but they
can't sleep that was my problem that was
my problem with 20s I was exhausted but
I couldn't say there was nights i didn't
sleep one minute i dark circles i would
lay there and i'm like twelve one two
three it was torture
it was torture so I know what that feels
like and it was terrible
okay so let me get back to the slides
here okay this is a this is a picture of
you thinking about your son's bad grades
the dishes um cleaning your inbox at
work right look familiar
Tyra can't sleep so you get on your
computer in the middle of the night bad
idea you should read a book I'm
fortunate these computers are really
kind of kind of wiring our bodies in our
nervous system because we're staring at
just this this thing about two feet away
from us and it's a it's a picture you're
looking at pictures and these pictures
are stuck there even when you go to
sleep and that's why I'm telling you you
need to get out and walk and get outside
um maybe you're here's another symptom
of adrenal low endurance like you just
don't have the stamina you don't have
the endurance um loss of strength you
climb up stairs and you're out of breath
your legs are heavier
craving salty chips that's an adrenal
symptom right so there's a couple
nutritional things that you can do one
is potassium but I like to get that from
the food lots of vegetables magnesium
you get it from the food same thing a
lot of vegetables magnesium will help
the heart a lot especially for blood
pressure the B vitamins are essential b1
b3 b5 this one's a really important one
for the adrenal and b6 b5 and b6 are
kind of like that cofactors in a lot of
hormones and neurotransmitters that help
you sleep so those are really those are
burned up during stress and then of
course vitamin C because vitamin C
basically makes you beat the adrenal so
it helps the the production of adrenal
hormones and most of the vitamin C in
your body is stored in the adrenal and
so stress can deplete vitamin C best
vitamin C you can consume would be in
bell peppers and green beans believe it
or not so here we go exercise right go
for the best for sleep is long walks I'm
talking like an hour just getting space
not listening to music just getting to a
park looking at stuff the problem is
it's getting darker and we can't do that
right now so yes I do exercise in the
dark on my bike with lights but it is a
problem unfortunately so you're going to
probably have to take a little vitamin D
vitamin k2 because it's getting dark but
you want to maybe spend a little time
maybe at your lunch for a walk to get
outside and you see me in this left
slide I'm looking at things you need
space that is what we need when you
exercise you you stress your body and
then you recover with sleep you don't
want to spike your pulse rate too much
you wanna a low stress long duration
type of exercise where you're calm and
you're feeling good and you there's no
stress that would be the best thing get
out there and go walk and and get space
um the other thing is that how many of
you work
athletes in your former life when you're
growing up or let's say high school or
college how many were like very athletic
and as you're typing I'm going to answer
some questions is it okay to walk in the
morning for dinner
totally fine now if you have pain with
your back Jane you can't walk far I
suggest you go to my website and get
that pain program that I have that you
can do it yourself and help help with
pain and I do a lot of demonstrations
with that so we can get rid of your pain
um yeah so there's some people that were
athletic some people were not well the
point that I'm making with the athletes
is if you go through your like early
time and you've you've done some intense
workouts we like even myself college
wrestling pushing myself and then I
stopped working out for ten years my
mitochondria are so big so I can
generate a lot of energy if I go to work
and go to bed at night
there's too much energy in my body so I
physically every single day have to
extract this energy by working out and
so I'm doing all sorts yeah Tracy was in
the reserves 20s yeah I was five years
in Army Reserves Fort Jackson South
Carolina but what happens is that I have
to physically workout now to extract
energy so every day I ride my bike I run
I do all sorts of things my backyard I'm
lifting these logs right now they're
very heavy across the lawn and I'm
cutting cutting wood so for me that's
the best thing for my body because I can
and I'm also doing those ropes where you
actually go back and forth on the tree
I'll actually did do a video on that
that's a really good workout um now
Lindsey says for the last several years
she hasn't had no motivation to exercise
to workout and I'm only 31 years old
yeah well I think what you have to do
Lindsey is really work on your sleep and
and your BA and your foods in nutrition
first okay so you can generate the
energy to be able to work out okay
because I don't recommend working out
unless you have the energy but I do want
you to walk you can always walk ok so so
in other words if you an athlete you're
going to have to physically exercise
every day more intensely to get the
energy out maybe you might need to keep
your pulse rate low if you can't if
you're not recovering um but that's
basically what you have to do now the
other thing I want to mention
yeah chopping wood is I mean I can for
me my body was designed to chop wood I
can do that all day I just love it my
body loves that chopping wood so as my
wife she likes me chopping wood
um ok so the other point I want to make
with sleeping is some people have a
breathing problem they're not breathing
that well they're like air hunger there
sighing frequently and that could be
because two reasons one that is more of
an acidosis type thing because when
you're on a ketosis diet you're burning
fat your pH will become more acidic and
I just did a video on that of people too
alkaline but you can be more acidic too
and the breathing what you do is if you
if you take calcium magnesium just one
on an empty stomach or before bed that
will help your breathing if that's what
it is
okay other reasons why you can't breathe
our vitamin C deficiency is severe
vitamin C deficiency where you have
bleeding gums to Beca beer or spider
veins so you want to consume a food base
vitamin C for that ok so that's just
some tips on that let me just kind of go
right here Oh
is a picture of the full spectrum light
you can get it ordered on Amazon or just
get it it's called natural light balance
like I would get one for your office and
then for you you know just to cutting so
you can get some of this light in your
face so if you don't you can't go
outside you can least get a dose of this
stuff okay so let's talk about stress
extraction there is an acupressure
technique many of you have been on my
other webinars you've seen me talk about
acupressure you know it's so funny
though if anyone thinks acupressure is
weird
it is not weird how else are you going
to extract your body stress you have to
physically manually pull it out and we
deal with acupressure acupressure is not
weird like versus what's weird to me is
taking a pill taking a drug but
acupressure is I'm not talking about
like traditional acupressure I'm talking
about the acupressure that that I
developed because I basically work on
the different stress points okay but
those points you can create some serious
improvement very fast by extracting
stress now the point that I want to talk
about is right in the brainstem back
here you see that point back there and
it's called the look locus coeruleus in
there appendicular
now what the heck does that mean those
are two little centers that control the
sleep and awake patterns of your body so
you take you see this try this is a
tripod you got the thin one you got the
wide one and the medium you did for
different people I'm going to take the
wide one I'm going to stick it on these
points right back here about the
brainstem and I'm going to sit back and
I'm going to kick up my feet and I'm
going to just lay here for about two
minutes and I do this every night before
I go to sleep I do this acupressure tool
and I'm going to hit those points for
about two minutes and I'm just going to
let go unconscious because it's it's a
it stimulates natural you don't have to
put electric things in your in your head
you can just do it manually and it
relaxes the tension in the back of the
neck and the whole spine relaxes you can
sleep really good so that's one point
this
other points I'm going to show you too
you know you can take your thumbs
impress those points it's more difficult
like this but you can sort of do it if
your if your shoulders are okay I use a
salt I use my couch actually and then
I'll go in my bedroom and I'll I'll do
these points right here okay now these
points are the adrenal points I'll start
with my right side and I'll work out
this point and then I'll work out this
point and I'll work at this point and
I'll slowly work up this side and then
I'll slowly work up this side and I'll
find pockets of tension that I'll work
out and and then I'll do my mid-back so
there's several things that you can do
to help extract the stress from the
adrenals and I'll show you the book that
I have on it and I'll show you where you
can get the device in a minute but the
point is that these are the adrenal
points and all of you should do these
points every night if you're not
sleeping so you can actually but I
actually do it on myself but I'm doing
on someone else there too okay I just
have to touch on this this is really
cool
I want you to type in um if you've ever
had an injury to your head skull injury
so type in if you've ever had a head
injury where your head hits the cement
or even unconscious or your head hits
something because I'll tell you one
thing um if you had an old head injury
that could be the reason why you're not
sleeping and why is that
I can't tell you the number of people
that I've run across where I'm doing all
the normal things and all of a sudden I
hit the skull points
I'll do the acupressure and skull points
and boom they go right to sleep so let
me show you something you got these
sutures that come through here and right
through in here
and you can actually press down down
into these sutures and start really
working these points with your thumb you
can have someone do it too and that'll
give you a lot of relief in your skull
but the key is this if you hit your head
let's say on this side then you want to
press into the injury or you can press
on the opposite side right here if you
hit your head right here you want to
press down into the injury if you hit
your head back here you want to press
down an injury or the opposite side
don't press where you hit your head
press on the opposite side when that
your skull is really relaxed and you can
actually you can even use this thing
right here you can kind of come into the
same gently press forward and work on
the sutures it basically opens the whole
skull and your head just feels so
comfortable so it's something that oh
well all of you have had concussions oh
my gosh full of ladder yeah so I think
some of you are going to need more
advanced work and I have them a lot of
you listening what came flew out who did
came to my seminar I did it's a
four-hour seminar I have it all recorded
it's on my website you can you have to
purchase it but it's a course that you
can take on acupressure I teach you
everything I teach you all the adrenal
points all the advanced adrenal points
I'm showing you some superficial things
right now and if you if you if you have
a serious problem you need to get that
and that will help you and it's um I
condensed I took out all the silent
period so it's actually only three hours
but it's some pretty powerful stuff
because I actually give you all the
techniques in that and you go send the
shopping cart all the way down on the
left hand side dr. Burke advanced
acupressure okay so now next thing when
I get into is let me find this thing
here oh this is a
here I did a seminar this is recently
and I'll send you the slides you can
click click this later but we are able
to demonstrate these techniques and
everywhere in the room it was amazing
and you'll see that before and afters
and then I had everyone practiced it so
they loved it
now I'm going to talk about supplement
support um and then this is a this is
called the stress kit there's an adrenal
formula there's a night formula and a
lot of you that are listening already
have these products but I'm just going
to show you if you don't this is the
tool you can get up that link and it
comes with this one and this one right
here now this one you take one before
bed if you have a real seriously
problems you take two this has all the
food for the adrenal to actually help
calm the adrenal down helps the recovery
helps the neurotransmitters it has every
single nutrient to support the
precursors to the neurotransmitters it
does not have melatonin I didn't want
that in there because that messes up the
gland that's a hormone this has
glandular extract for the adrenal and
the pituitary so it's pretty serious
adrenal stuff and then and also you
might want to take one maybe two before
bed and you will be sleeping better
sometimes if you if you have a bad
problem and you need like let's say you
wake up at 4:00 you can take one more
and then really go to sleep now this one
this one's during the day and you take 3
to 6 so this handles like stress it has
all of the natural B vitamins there's no
synthetics but and it comes from
nutritional yeast but not the type of
yeast that gives you a yeast infection a
lot of times people when they get
nutritional yeast the end up with a
yeast thing like an overgrowth this one
doesn't have that version ok so it's
pretty pretty awesome it has to be 5
would be 3 to be 6 to be 1 so this is
really good in combination with this for
sleep and stress okay so you'll feel
calm and your tolerance for incompetent
people will go way way up so all three
of those
and then the book if you don't have the
book and you have my device already just
call us we'll send you one and you can
also get the download too but we send
this out and it goes through all the
stress points right here so that is what
what you want to do so um let me just
pull this up again yeah so basically for
those of you that don't have this you
need to get this because this will
handle the adrenals from two different
angles from a nutritional angle and from
a stress angle you'll learn a technique
to pull stress out and it's it's the
most popular kit and it'll roto-rooter
any type of adrenal issues that you have
nutritionally this is just the formula
right here all the different things it
has in it GABA um for toe root root
which is amazing it has a food base
vitamin-c complex anterior pituitary not
the posterior the answer to help that
whole pathway so it's some serious
nutrition for the adrenal and then the
day formula has a combination of a lot
of different types of potassium minerals
as well as calcium magnesium and
nutritional herbal things for the stress
from the adrenal so that's that's what
that has in it let me just come back
here let me just pull up something for
you see here
I'm trying to find this thing here okay
yeah third is okay so yeah so basically
that's the stress kit for those of you
they're asking how can I get those
products go ahead and get that if you
don't have that end we'll ship it out
like tomorrow and you start taking it in
the meantime use an end of a brush for
your adrenals
and start working on them don't use a
knife like that you know you're going to
hurt yourself because someone has some
questions how late in the day should I
take the adrenal day formula you can
take that one
all the way up until dinnertime is not a
problem um let's see here okay so let's
see here oh yeah is it suitable for
vegetarians absolutely now the gland the
adrenal day formula has in it vegetarian
products but the adrenal night formula
does have some glandular extracts but I
have a lot of vegetarians that consumer
because it doesn't have hormones it's
organic and it basically it really helps
them sleep because it's it's a little
bit difficult to take something without
those glandulars and have it really work
well because you don't want to take one
glandulars with hormones too um let's
see here would it be safe to take if you
add cortisol for drain for yeah it's
basically designed to lower and balance
cortisol so it's it's for people that
have high cortisol levels do the adrenal
supplements have any side effects like
skin darkening no no no because it
improves the adrenal what causes the
skin darkening is um low cortisol like
really excessively low cortisol that's
Addison's disease
this just balances it to a normal level
um Mary since I take the adrenal d-day
formula it's amazing how much calmer I
feel when I take it yeah it's awesome
and plus the quality of the bees in
there are so good I mean it just helps
with all the the different chemical
reactions that occur because when you go
through stress you deplete your bees so
it really helps with a lot of different
things for health and sleeping um
someone said the screen has not moved in
last 15 minutes well I'll send you the
link because it is working another other
people can see it on the supplements
gluten-free and non-gmo of course they
are I am very much against GMO and
gluten so yes melatonin is that bad well
yeah because it's a hormone it does work
but the problem is when any time you
think about this melatonin is stimulated
by darkness melatonin stimulates and
converts to serotonin which goes through
this whole cascade of sleep patterns
when you take melatonin directly it
causes the pineal gland not to have to
work anymore making you dependent on the
melatonin so now the pineal gland starts
to shrink more and more and more and
more to the point where it dries up and
you don't it doesn't work anymore and
you need one more melatonin to achieve
that so it kind of it throws off it's
not the best thing to take in the world
I mean you can take it on a short-term
basis but I don't like it very good
questions how truly
operation date well these are on some of
them have expiration dates some of them
I have the manufacturing date and
they're good for three years after the
manufacturing date but they're actually
good for you the longer because I I've
taken some of mine for a long time and
I'll like I won't take them and I'll
take them they still work but you know I
mean it's good for at least three years
um you said three to six a day on the
adrenal day oh okay so you want to take
if you if you want to see a dramatic
results do 2 to 2 with meals ok as the
maintenance do one one one but this will
create some calmness I mean I saw this
husband and wife and the wife was very
stressed out so I told husband I said
give her one of these before shillings
and then put her in the back seat she's
gonna want to take a nap because she
just she was so high-strung so it just
calmed right down and he came back and
he Isis how did she do she goes would be
you're right she just like wanted to
take a nap she felt so calm but it's not
necessarily for fatigue it will calm the
Drina 'ls and you'll feel more relaxed
so you can sleep that night um are the B
vitamins methylated well guess what
they're naturally method ated because
they're all from nutritional yeast but
they're they don't have the part that
creates the yeast overgrowth so yes
they're natural they're not made
synthetically you don't want to consume
synthetic B vitamins and it's hard to
find natural beauty items so yes these
are the real deal and that's why I
wanted to create something with natural
developments how much time taking the
formula can I see the sleeping proof it
should work the first time you take it
ok this one I like to take a half hour
to an hour before I go to bed so I can
wind down
but you don't need more than two okay
and then you do the acupressure on
yourself as well there are seven places
when you do the acupressure you do the
next point you do the adrenals you do
there's other points that you would use
and then you can take it where you go
but a lot of people love this thing and
it just helps them sleep I I created
this for myself because I had a sleeping
problem and and I said I wanted to be
able to treat myself so that was pretty
cool and I also give you a link to show
you what to do to get rid of old
injuries of your head Addison's disease
is a low adrenal and the remedies for
high adrenal and Load renal are the same
so you do the same protocol for high low
because it's still a stress case can I
give my adrenal day to my
seventeen-year-old absolutely yeah
there's not really an age limit
yeah there's there is magnesium and
calcium in the adrenal support but you
can always take extra not a problem the
only thing I'm against is taking too
much calcium and calcium carbonate
that's limestone do not take calcium
carbonate ever that's very bad what
about using 5-htp 5-htp is a precursor
to l-tryptophan which turns into
tryptophan which is turns in the
serotonin it's the whole pathway I like
that I like health tryptophan I like
5-hydroxytryptophan the ingredients in
here work a lot better but sometimes I
might use both if I want to create a
even a bigger effect like let's say I'm
flying across the country and I had to
ask I need to go to bed a certain time
I'll take this in l-tryptophan five
hydroxy 5-htp basically will will work
but I like l-tryptophan a little bit
better if I'm going to be traveling
because it's stronger because 5-htp
turns into l-tryptophan
really says I had one of those bulbs and
it made a huge difference well that is
awesome I love it and don't don't forget
as you actually improve things don't
forget to take a nap - because it's okay
to take naps to try to recover this the
B vitamins in folic acid what are the B
vitamins
well folic acid is one of the B vitamins
and folic acid is in the adrenal de
formula as well uh will the adrenal
day-and-night work if I work out nights
absolutely it will work what about
taking out tryptophan with adrenal night
yeah yeah you can take that now that
would enhance enhance the sleep effect
really this is how much longer is the
web webinar going to be not very much
longer
I'm just going to answer a couple more
questions because I plan on doing one
hour and it went over again when you
think about valerian root valerian root
makes me feel kind of tired you know
when I wake up groggy I need to eat
something with adrenal formula because
my heartburn yeah you probably need to
eat something with that not a problem
but if you eat the problem with
l-tryptophan if you eat protein with it
it won't work so you have to not eat
protein without tryptophan that's an
amino acid it won't go in just a little
side them so why not take glandulars
with hormones like melatonin because
it's going to inactivate your own gland
any time you take a hormone your glands
don't have to work anymore
so that's the problem so I want to thank
you guys for coming on my webinar I hope
you got some tips and I really
appreciate your interest do me a big
favor and write a review on the app if
you see any bugs email me and I want to
I want to fix them I hopefully there's
not any bugs but I'm gonna I'm going to
create a lot of um
new videos that relate to some really
cool stuff coming up in the next couple
weeks so thank you very much it was a
wonderful talking everyone and I
appreciate all your wonderful comments
and have a great I have a nice night ok
we'll see you soon